this is not a movie made for kids but
kids can watch it if their parents talk
to them for years we didn't even know if
this movie was going to be made but
Guillermo del Toro refused to give up
and it seems that spending half of his
career championing his Pinocchio
adaptation has finally paid off let's
look back on what it was that made this
movie so difficult to make you know at
one point we had 60 units
shooting at the same time number one
that's right most everything in this
film is real the animation team fought
hard against using CG animation in
nearly every circumstance building sets
with trap doors for the animators to
manipulate the mechanical puppets
through and even suspending tiny props
like ashes or popcorn up on wires so
that it can all be shot practically the
ocean is one of the very few things that
CG animated and Guillermo del Toro even
wanted to give that the appearance of
being stop motion like a cross between a
real ocean and a gelatin ocean number
two it's the flaws that make something
beautiful Guillermo del Toro wanted his
puppets to feel real and so his goal was
to provoke from these puppets stumbles
itchings sweat joints that hurt and make
them transmit to the audience what they
feel the animators Were Meant to follow
a series of guidelines that went as
follows try to animate mistakes animate
failed parts anime characters listening
animate micro gestures and avoid
pantomime all in an attempt to make them
feel more human number three this sure
shows dedication when asked about the
most difficult shot in the movie Del
Toro pointed to one scene where
spazatura the monkey leads us through a
carnival to one of the film's villains
in a single shot this scene took around
two and a half months to set up and
between three weeks to a month to
actually shoot three special tour
puppets were destroyed in the making of
This scene a sacrifice Guillermo del
Toro was willing to make for that
perfect shot number four how big does a
wooden boy have to be would you believe
us if we said that Pinocchio was this
big in some scenes this is her Pinocchio
to interact with the cricket the
animation team had to pay close
attention to both size and scale meaning
that every character required multiple
puppets in varying sizes whenever
Pinocchio has the Cricket on his
shoulder older our leading puppet needed
to be very big compared to the little
bug and yet for other scenes we use this
small Penelope number five he really is
one of a kind as the wooden boy
Pinocchio needed to stand out and so to
make sure that his design looked more
Fantastical than the others the
Pinocchio puppet was 3D printed with
replacement face and body parts the body
is made out of titanium and provided
with plenty of joint Movement by English
animation studio McKinnon and Saunders
in fact Pinocchio is the only puppet to
have been fully printed from a 3D
printer to date number six whenever
possible the animators tried to film in
twos this is a technique in stop motion
animation that actually cuts the amount
of frames per second from the Standard
24 all the way down to 12. although this
technique was previously thought to
result in more stuttered animation
Pinocchio's animation supervisor Brian
Lee Hansen aims to prove that she
shooting and choose can instead create
more nuanced and realistic
characterization number seven Gregory
Mann was never even in the same room as
Pinocchio when asked if he got to see or
interact with the puppet much on set the
young actor replied that was one picture
I saw of Google and that was it instead
Guillermo del Toro would record the
actors as faces while they were in the
sound booth so that the animators could
then base the puppet's Expressions off
of their voice actors number eight what
does the world of a wooden boy sound
like this was the first question that
the film's composer Alexander despla
found himself faced with when it came
time to construct the score his answer
was simple but effective I tried with
the score to bring the music also in the
world of the puppets by using only wood
instruments he would later go on to say
that limiting himself to using only wood
instruments was a good challenge and
that there's a certain softness to the
sound of wood that certainly added an
extra element to the film number nine
Pinocchio's father is meant to feel the
most human as such his design was the
first to be approved and the one that
went through the least amount of changes
from Sketchbook to screen many of the
more Fantastical characters went through
more substantial design changes over
time all of which have been documented
in Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio a
Timeless tale told Anew by Gina McIntyre
this book from inside editions gives
fans an illustrated look into the
journey behind the film's character
designs puppet building and ruling
animation process number 10 let's hear
it for the animators Guillermo del Toro
has gone out of his way to celebrate the
work his animation team did on Pinocchio
even going so far as to State one
significant step on Pinocchio is that we
credit the animators right up front
alongside the cast members because they
are he hopes that this will have a
revolutionary effect on the movie
industry as animators tend to be
overlooked despite the very important
role they play in a film's success
number 11. for a while it looked like
this movie wasn't going to exist
Guillermo del Toro first pitched the
idea 15 years ago and though he would
describe it at the time as the movie
he's always wanted to make it would
almost seem as though the project had
been canceled entirely when he couldn't
find a studio to back it refusing to
give up Del Toro ultimately sold the
idea to Netflix in 2018 sending the film
into five years of intense
pre-production and production number 12.
Guillermo del Toro loved Pinocchio
growing up and ever since his mother
first gave him carved Pinocchio
figurines he tried to replicate them at
age 11 and never stopped I told my mom
you think I could do a Pinocchio and she
said yeah you can over the 15 years that
Del Toro was trying to get Pinocchio
greenlit his mother would tell him
that's the movie I want to see before
the world premiere of Pinocchio at the
EFI London Film Festival Del Toro took
the stage to honor his mother who passed
away only one day prior she was able to
see a few scenes and the trailer
beforehand though number 13. the rules
were made to be broken Guillermo del
Toro knew he wanted his version of
Pinocchio to explore the value of
Disobedience and so he took plenty of
inspiration from the artwork of Grace
Grimley grimly Drew Pinocchio in such a
way as to make him look Untamed yet
innocent his artwork is often far darker
in nature when it comes to the threats
that Pinocchio faces throughout the book
as well making it the perfect source of
inspiration for this horror director
number 14. why did Guillermo del Toro
put his name before the title because
this is his version of Pinocchio he's
intentionally changed certain details
like setting and theme to put his own
spin on the classic tale with his
version taking place in 1930s Italy this
new setting is meant to explore as Del
Toro described it an environment in
which citizens behave with obedient
almost puppet-like faithfulness wherein
Pinocchio shows others the value of
Disobedience rather than learning to
behave this version certainly promises
to be different from Walt Disney's
Pinocchio number 15. exciting news for
Guillermo del Toro fans he considers
Pinocchio to be the completion of a
Trilogy that he started with the Devil's
Backbone and Pan's Labyrinth all three
movies deal with the subject matter of
childhood and War and use fairy tales as
a means to explore them if you look
closely you may even notice a couple of
Easter eggs scattered throughout the
film such as the fawn from Pan's
Labyrinth and one of the windows as well
as little gestures to the Devil's
Backbone
Pinocchio was clearly a special project
for Guillermo del Toro and it's one that
he's spent 15 years trying to get just
right do you think all that hard work
and passion paid off let us know what
you think down in the comments